jase anderson has also seen the mets
twice starting on april 6 and april 13th
against new york he's owned two in those
contests brandon nimmo leads off
anderson as we said wearing
short sleeves all the way the white
pinstripe uniform the 2-2 strike called
on the outside corner and nemo knew it
good pitch right there no doubt about it
that'll bring up
jeff mcneal he might swing at the first
pitch
pretty good chance
curveball did he go yes he did since the
home plate up fire two strikeouts for
chase anderson well he was around the
plate the entire inning the last time
the philly saw marcus strowman well he
was pretty good in fact the fields have
seen him twice this year he won six
innings in both of those contests two
men away and rhys hoskins coming up
here's the 01 on the way
reached four and hit in the air to right
field well that'll stay in the park
conforto there makes the one hand catch
side retired strowman with a one two
three first just eight pitches no score
pete alonso will lead off here in the
second
here's the one two pitch swung on and
rip to left mccutchen to his left a
couple of steps he makes to catch
and nearly got
bowled over by the breeze i think out
there
look at the eyes on mccutchen couldn't
believe how fast that ball got to him
the wind was pushing it forward the
the ball was pushing him back
here's james mccann with two on 2-0
swinging a high pop up right field
right field line look at the wind tape
he stayed with it and he was able to
keep his eyes on it
and make the grab to end the inning
nothing is routine with the wind blowing
the way it's blowing here tonight boom
batting at 216 with two home runs and 13
runs batted in
and a late swing and a high slider
and strowman has his first strike out of
the night as he gets bowled one away
so now the base is loaded with two down
and here is anderson a lifetime 0.93
hitter over four this year
swing it a miss it gets away from mccann
it goes past the on deck circle one is
in two are in
hustling all the way around
is andrew knapp and the phillies take a
two-nothing lead on a strikeout
i would think past ball
mccutchen flied to center his first time
up
one two pitch
swung on and missed strike three got him
with a slider two nothing fills after
two
alonzo batting with two on and two out
swinging a miss he threw the cutter and
he got him three strikeouts for chase
anderson as the mets leave two more
joyce grounded out his first time up
and a good sinker by stroma to strike
out joyce for the first out that's his
fourth strikeout rhys hoskins will be
the batter fly to right his first time
2-2 coming to hoskins and he struck him
out
back-to-back strikeouts for strowman in
fact he's now struck out the last four
hitters
see if james mccann can come through
two balls two strikes to the pitch
swinging a miss he struck him out
and mccann goes down on strikes that's
number five on the night for chase
anderson
no runs a hit the man left by the mets
we're going to the bottom of the fourth
it's two-nothing phillies holmes struck
out his first time rookie of the year
runner-up
oh two to bone
and it's called strike three on the
outside corner so that is six straight
strikeouts
for marcus strowman seven on the night
and there's one away here in the fourth
new season high in strikeouts for
strowman with seven
as andrew knapp will be the batman
and andrew knapp is a strikeout victim
and that's now eight for strowman who
had not struck out more than five in a
game this year but he's down two nothing
after four in philly
so now mcneal
who has struck out and drawn a walk
the o2
swinging the ground ball right back at
anderson he ducks down and makes the
play flips it over to first mcneil slams
the bat down on his way down the line
now
slams the helmet down as well
chase anderson's got five scoreless
under his belt tonight
and we're headed for the bottom of the
fifth it's the phillies two in the mets
nothing no runs ahead the man left in
scoring position the bets are old for
nine with runners in scoring position
tonight we go to the bottom of the fifth
j.d davis is two for two he is singled
and doubled tonight he's got runners on
first and second philly's up two nothing
romero's gone back even two balls and
two strikes to jd davis and that one's
hit toward third picked on one hop by
balm he can't get out of his glove he
throws low to first in time to get jd
davis
really great play on the backhand right
here
and you can see it almost popped out of
his glove oh man
anyway the mets now have the tying runs
in scoring position with dom smith at
the plate and dom slashes one through
the hole for a base hand that'll bring
it alonzo conforto stops at third the
mitsub score to run
dom smith with an opposite field single
the mets snapped their 21-inning scoring
drought it's now 2-1
and an albatross has been lifted
from the mets collective shoulders
now mccann who has flied out and is
struck out
one man down
here's the 2-0 pitch swing and a ground
ball left side boehm's got it second one
on to first double play
well he gets it out of the glove this
time five four three to go around the
horn
one run in the inning on two hits it was
one man left we'll go to the bottom of
the six phillies hold the lead it's two
to one
phillies have runners on first and
second with o'double herrera do a
one-two pitch
it's this ball hard on the ground snack
by mcneil throws to second base one
lindor to first down in time
the empire at first scott berry says
alonso came off the bag the throw was a
little bit high as herrera was able to
beat out the play at first
good play by mcneil ranging to his left
the bases are loaded as andrew mccutchen
will get a chance
2-2 coming to mccutcheon
in there for a full strike three
familia got the call at the top of the
zone andrew mccutchen went into the
dugout after striking out against
jerry's familia and he had a fight with
the batman top of the eighth is alvarado
against jeff mcneil here's the pitch to
mcneil
inside it hit him he got him it looked
like around the elbow mcneil is wincing
as he starts to walk towards first base
but the mets will take it bring up pete
alonso
fly ball right center field on the run
is herrera and here comes roman quinn
and they collide oh double has it
mcneil's going to second
he'll slide in safely and roman's coming
up limping
he dropped his glove and he's limping
toward the warning track hopefully he
walks it off
and conforto waiting
they will be facing each other
after this happened earlier this month
first a pitch inside that was head high
that got the dugout angry and then
angrier after he got hit on the arm by a
pitch
dom smith was saying first one at his
head then you hit him have a clue
two balls no strikes to conforto
loops it out toward left field here
comes joyce and he makes the diving grab
two outs here in the eighth inning
so dom smith the one man who has a hit
in this game with been in scoring
position
is being challenged here by the phillies
and now the lefty jose alvarado runners
lead off
and the 3-2 pitch
swing gonna miss he got him
alvarado
found the strike zone at the ends
and he's yelling at dominic smith oh he
threw his glove away
the benches are going to clear
alvarado's being held back by alec baum
alvarado better be careful
this goes back to the conforto hit by
pitch from alvarado in new york a few
weeks ago and alvarado clearly was
inviting that confrontation
a lot of bullpens are coming charging in
as well
to join
this uh
join match
alvarado being restrained everybody else
is pretty calm this is all about
alvarado and him taking offense to the
mets taking offense to
him drilling a couple of players
look forward to a couple of weeks ago
mcneil tonight
should have went and got him that was
classless
3-0 now to hoskins
and there's ball four to hoskins and
hoskins has some words for castro
thinking that maybe miguel was throwing
inside as a response to alvarado and now
castro walking in hoskins direction and
the umpires have to get between
so this is going to be an ongoing saga
with these two clubs all year and he's
trying to
stop this from becoming a brawl because
there's a chance it could become a brawl
the go-ahead run coming to the plate and
it's francisco lindor a one
bouncer to first pull up by rhys hoskins
on the dive stumbles to the first base
bag and the ball game is over the
phillies hang on and win it two to one